Earlier in your talk you mentioned vaccines and autism and that's such a hot button issue a lot of people think that it's either yes
They cause or know they don't but a lot of people that we've talked you said it's it's a more gray area
That there's also some things that come into play in addition to
Vaccines that can trigger what you know, what have you seen? What do you think?
well
I'm not a big fan of vaccines
But if you look at the theory of vaccines
I mean the purpose of a vaccine is to give a person a small dose of the disease. Let's use measles
So that it stimulates go back to the immune system. It stimulates a
TH1 response to help that's trying to kill the measles and you have to have enough of a dose that
That person's body can't kill it so it'll stimulate a TH2 response. That's the B cell response that will make antibodies
So that's why a vaccine a person that's vaccinated isn't necessarily immunized
So in immunization is that that person has circulated antibodies against the thing that you vaccinated against
So if I could measure
Vaccines the measles antibodies in my blood a month after I got vaccinated then it worked, right?
The problem is how do I know a dosage to give this person that's gonna stimulate a TH1 and a TH2 response so I make antibodies against that thing
Well, you can't even dose a based upon weight
It's totally based upon that person's immune response, which is gonna be individual
So you're they're just guessing so in theory if
Vaccines actually stimulated a TH2 response and made that that person made antibodies against that thing in every case that vaccines are
Miracle, right?
The problem is is that in order to stimulate that
TH2 response in a person you have to give enough of the measles that it's gonna give the person measles
Usually, so then they have to add these things these chemicals into the vaccines called adjuvunks
That will be other things to stimulate an immune response
So that hopefully the B cell response will make antibodies against the measles and not against the other things because the other things are
Inert that you can't make antibodies against so in theory vaccination is phenomenal in
Real life it doesn't work quite so well
especially when you're dealing with a
6-pound baby that has no blood brain barrier yet and
You're pumping them with the adjuvunks that if they have
defects on the
Detoxification pathways that are supposed to get rid of those adjuvunks
They're gonna circulate in the blood circulate in the blood because they because the liver is gonna be a slow detox
They're because of those defects and they're gonna settle somewhere and if it settles in the brain
It could cause all sorts of problems
Not just you know, we want to go. Oh, vaccines cause autism
Well, vaccines can cause you can't argue with that. It's just physiology
But they don't cause autism at everybody so if you have really healthy detox pathways that baby does
They could just flush those adjuvunks out and have no problems
It's when they don't have healthy detox pathways either because of genetic defects or because this baby was
Was you know, the mother was on medications and so that baby's liver is already taxed or because
They're recommending Tylenol after a vaccine which shuts down a whole bunch of the methylation pathways. That's a whole nother conversation
Then they're gonna be much slower detoxers. So there's there's other factors that are involved
That should be addressed and but if I mean most general practitioners giving out vaccines don't understand anything
I just said about genetics because if you're not educated in that matter, it's kind of foolishness
So I recommend if you want to vaccinate your child, that's great. You should know what you should know what their genetic pathways are like beforehand
They got pond one pathways. They have MTHFR pathway defects. They have cytochrome P50 pathway defects
And you're gonna vaccinate well, you know good luck with that. That's to be child abuse
And that's just and the sad thing is is people are ignorant to that but there isn't a reason the the knowledge is out there
Maybe there's just not a lot of people that know what I'm saying is true
But you could do your own research and understand that where these adjuvugs detox on the pathways that the detox on it look at that yourself
But to know that
Is important to not know that could be a grave decision that you make